we also say good morning to build
Livingston the great columnist for the
clean plate Cleveland Plain Dealer how
would you describe last night bill
probably one of the great nights in
Cleveland sports history it was lit up
like Las Vegas as LeBron promised when
he was a rookie you know a very
spectacular ring ceremony with LeBron
when they when they raised the banner to
the roof he went over they had the you
know that's just this gaudy ridiculously
sized ring he went over with the finger
that bore the ring he touched the banner
and as it began to rise up you could
tell I mean he was very moved he started
wiping away tears as he walked back to
take his place with his teammates
because he had dedicated all of last
season to that I had you know some
Nick's riders near me and until they
needed the stats in the fourth quarter I
didn't really I was covering the ring
ceremony and then going to duck out and
try to get some of the atmosphere of the
other right across the plaza I had the
World Series game on with the sound off
on the monitor and what they showed all
of the Indians runs on the they don't
call it a Jumbotron in Cleveland an it's
a humungo Tron it has four sides and the
roars were every bit as loud for that as
for the constant replays of lebron's
block of andre iguodala and also they
had all three by the big three in the
seventh game the shot by irving and the
stop by love on Steph Curry it was just
constant roars all over downtown the
plaza was absolutely packed they had a
big screen huge thing you know watch
party thing out there with sometimes you
know you'd hear aurora in jaén i keep
wanting to call it jacobs field and
progressive field them you'd see what it
was about but it was it was tremendous
it was LeBron said it's a night anyone
who was here will always remember in any
yelled cleveland against the world and i
ended my column Sam well right now it's
Cleveland to world nothing it's just
surreal to you though bill if I would
have told you a couple of years ago you
were going to have a night like this
what would you said well I wouldn't have
believed
with Francona's manager i mean i thought
the cat I didn't think the cavs would
beat Golden State but but you know in
the East they are going to be the power
for a while anyway I thought they could
get back to the finals after losing and
you know they gave a decent account of
themselves with only LeBron as soon as
LeBron came back being east of the
Mississippi River I knew the Cavs are
going to be making deep playoff runs the
Indians are the ones that just given
everything that happened in losing three
three pitchers in their starting
rotation and it was the strength of the
team and not having Michael Brantley
their best position player last year for
virtually the entire season because he
couldn't come back from a shoulder
injury it really is just remarkable at
the Indians i was asking another show
who's the most popular team in town and
would it be the calves or the Indians
and I actually had to say the Cavs going
by regular season attendance because
they were selling out in the Indians
through 1.6 million with with a team
that took control of the division race
in late June and we're really never
headed although I think Detroit got
within two games they were never tired
or headed it's been a real shame with
with a great manager like Franklin with
this overachieving even now of course
it's just electric at progressive field
every night because everyone's behind
them now but it's really not all that
much of a baseball town usually but this
is one of those events put more pressure
on the Browns or less pressure oh I
think it's got to put more pressure on
the Browns and I think the Browns need
all the pressure you can put on I mean
you know this is a league that bends
over backwards to try to help teams that
are down and and they for this is their
17th year and you know they've been an
embarrassment really they've been what
the Bengals used to be with with crazy
off-field antics and an uncompetitive
team twenty seven or eight quarterbacks
I did a story recently where Ohio
State's had five coaches since Woody
Hayes came in 1951 five full-time
coaches four of them are already in the
College Hall of Fame urban meyer oddlies
obviously will be and they had one
interim coach with the scandal year with
Luke Fickell the Browns have had eight
head coaches and an interim
nineteen ninety nine three more than
Ohio State and none of them Belichick
wasn't here then none of them are going
to be mentioned for any Hall of Fame I
don't think I'm also wondering about we
were talking about an athlete's
importance to a city we saw this with
Big Papi in Boston or you could say Tom
Brady is is there an athlete more
important and I don't know historically
if we can look at it that way as well
but LeBron to Cleveland is there
somebody who's more important
historically I really don't think so I
was close with the irascible great Bob
Feller and loved hearing him tell
stories but you know this was before the
24 7 news cycle and the and social media
and all of that he was a local kid he
left he came back and it's it's not only
the way he plays I mean he's always been
a great player it's he came back a
different person he's he is active in
social causes good works the type of
things that Michael Jordan you know
never wanted to get involved in because
it would offend some people he has a
foundation that works in concert with
the university of akron to provide
scholarships for worthy kids from the
inner city in akron you know he's just
there you know you just got to say he's
been a tremendously good citizen ever
since he came back and he's a role model
in that respect and a basketball player
can make so much more impact than anyone
else in the other sports because he can
create a son shot there's only five
players on each team I think so I mean I
don't think there's ever been a sports
figure like him in Cleveland well enjoy
the ride bill must make those columns a
little bit easier to write well it's
going to be I'm glad they move the game
up it's going to be chilly and I hope
they get it in before the before the
rain tonight because i'll be i'll be at
the series the rest of the way thank you
Bill thanks Dan bill livingston
Cleveland Plain Dealer the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience